[Music]
today's question comes from alexander in
washington
my fiance and i are getting married late
next year we set a wedding budget of 25
000 and split the expenses based on
percent income percentage
we did this because we have not yet
combined incomes i'm worried that she
will not have her portion of money saved
up in time after three months she has
not made the progress we said was
necessary to stay in line with her
contributions
in the event that she does not meet her
goal should i cover her portion of the
wedding expenses it is not an engagement
ending situation however it is fundament
fundamentally important
to me that she achieved this goal i am
willing to tell her we didn't hit the
mark so we can't have flowers for the
wedding
but that seems cheap realistically how
hard knows should i be about the issue
gosh
you are a super nerd i would just
breathe alexander breathe
breathe in for four seconds hold
and breathe out
it's okay it's okay
oh alexander
oh
he's a little tense a little stressed
alexander it's fine you're fine you're
good listen
you're sweet fiance i mean
i don't yes i do not i pray it's not
engagement ending situation i mean if
she's going behind her back and lying
and a bunch of stuff but if she has not
hit the goals
necessary to the progress
fundamentally i think it's fine i think
you're fine i think you guys enjoy the
wedding i would turn the legalism notch
down like five notches
and she could probably teach you some
stuff alexander you know
poor like xander i'm starting hard on
you
the problem is the problem is what you
and i are seeing is we're seeing this is
gonna repeat itself yes and for the next
50 years
and uh the poor girl is never going to
make her goal
um in the 50 years and so uh what you've
got to do is you have to back up and go
okay this
goal and her not being there and there's
kind of there's a
alexander your voice sounds more like a
father than a fiance
yes it sounds very paternal
with your language
um like you are looking down your nose
at her a little bit like you have all
this figured out and the poor little
thing can't meet her goal yeah um
there's a little bit of uh
that aristocracy crap in here so um you
need to get your nose down your upper
lips gonna get sunburned but um
the um
so
yeah
so i think you need to address that part
of your all's relationship and this
meeting the goal for the wedding budget
is a symptom
of what's going on and so
she's not behaving like you think she
should behave and you are
uh
paternal in your approach
and so i i would say yeah you guys need
to sit down and go okay we gotta learn
to work as a team here and we're both
setting this goal we both have to carry
our weight and so what's this look like
did we did i miss something
how are we going to work together how
are we going to pull this together um
but instead of you uh determining in
advance when she fails how you're going
to grant her grace instead of being
cheap and dirty and cutting out the
flowers
right right
yeah it just sounded yeah no it does
it's it sounds it just sounds legalistic
to me so i think i think there's a lot
of guys and yeah and i i would want to
know the why obviously if she's sitting
there racking up a bunch of credit card
debt and spending money she doesn't have
in her life and all of that yeah that's
an issue because you guys aren't on the
same page on how money works but if she
just hasn't hit a certain goal maybe
because of her income or yeah maybe she
she just wasn't as strict on the budget
as she should have been i mean all of it
right like there's just
you know the reason that this
conversation is there is more important
than the actual yes issue yes yes
finding out why you guys need to work on
that in your pre-marriage counseling
because um you using this voice on her
sir long term it's not going to work
i can just tell you
that's how it is oh